[Musique]
chaque jour en Iran le bilan des
protestations continue de s’alourdir et
la mobilisation ne faiblit pas l'élément
déclencheur de ces révoltes c'est la
mort le 16 septembre dernier de Mazda
Amini cette jeune iranienne de 22 ans a
été arrêtée puis tué par la police des
mœurs pour non-respect du code
vestimentaire de la République islamique
d'Iran depuis les manifestants expriment
leurs colères dans tout le pays et
attendre un changement total du régime
actuel
alors cette révolte en Iran peut-elle se
transformer en révolution réponse dans
facture
[Applaudissements]
en réalité la mort de Massa Amélie n'a
fait que réveiller des tensions qui
existent depuis des années en Iran déjà
en 2009 après la réélection controversée
de l'ultra conservateur amadin nedjad
des millions d'Iraniens manifestent puis
fassez une économie en déclin les
Iraniens se retrouvent dans la rue en
2017 puis une nouvelle fois deux ans
plus tard en 2019 pour protester contre
la hausse des prix du carburant mais
aujourd'hui et contrairement à ces
révoltes précédentes le mouvement c'est
généralisé dans l'ensemble du pays
toutes les classes sociales aujourd'hui
toutes les catégories sociales toutes
les couches sociales partout dans la
société les gens se sont
identifiés se sont reconnus dans le sort
tragique de cette jeune fille et c'est
pourquoi là elle a à son insu et elle
saura jamais d'ailleurs elle a créé une
solidarité nationale une conscience
nationale qui n'a jamais été aussi forte
qu'aujourd'hui en Iran face à cette
situation de nombreuses personnalités du
monde entier ont exprimé leur soutien à
la population iranienne
[Musique]
il y a une forte présence de jeunes de
18 à 25 ans les jeunes qui sont nés qui
ont grandi devant les écrans de leur
ordinateur
dans les réseaux sociaux dans les
réseaux qui s'expriment systématiquement
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui s'y
retrouve il s'y retrouve il se parle le
soir et le lendemain ils sont dans la
rue il s'y retrouve il se il se
reconnaissent et donc les réseaux
sociaux en Iran sont devenus aujourd'hui
une
voix pour canaliser la colère d'une
jeunesse qui a été humiliée pendant très
longtemps l'envergure de ce mouvement sa
radicalité traduit une chose bien claire
ce mouvement va bien au-delà d'une
simple manifestation ce qui inquiète
l'État iranien ils ont peur de la
population ils ont peur de perdre leur
pouvoir et donc ils pensent que en
coupant internet ou en réprimant dans le
sang les manifestants pacifiques il
parviendront à
réprimer les contestataires mais au
contraire on voit que depuis les deux
trois dernières semaines
les mécontentements se sont répandues à
l'ensemble du pays à l'ensemble des
groupes sociaux l'état cran en tout cas
un bouleversement majeur l'état craint
aussi que ces forces de coercition
s'efforce armées changent donc pour
l'instant ça n'est pas le cas pour
l'instant les forces armées restent sous
le contrôle du guide ramenéi qui est le
chef des armées mais la crainte de
pouvoir c'est que si les manifestations
continuent s'il arrêt pression continue
à un moment une partie de ses forces de
coercition de force armée vont peut-être
changer de camp et dire on refuse de
continuer à tirer sur les manifestants
pacifiques je pense qu'ils sont assez
intelligents pour comprendre quand même
que ils sont dans la pire crise de leur
existence ils sont assez intelligents
pour comprendre l'ampleur des dégâts
qu'ils ont fait dans ce pays et ici
attendez quelque part parce que depuis
quelques années il n'arrête pas de dire
vous voyez on est encore là il
s'attendait qu'il soit parti déjà et
bien il se surprennent eux-mêmes alors
pouvons-nous déjà parler de révolution
prenons l'exemple de la révolution
iranienne de 1979 les premières
manifestations en réalité débuté un an
plus tôt en 1978 à cette époque les
femmes étaient notamment libres de
marcher avec qui elle voulait elle
pouvait aussi choisir de porter le voile
ou non mais c'était une dictature il y
avait peu de liberté politique puis
c'est en 1979 après la révolution que la
police des mœurs a été créée avec pour
mission assurer l'application de la loi
islamique aujourd'hui cette police est
fortement remise en cause et l'objectif
des Iraniens est simple renverser le
régime et cela peu importe le temps que
ça prendra moi je pense que la
révolution a été déjà déclenchée c'est
une révolution cette fois-ci pas
seulement des femmes également des
jeunes hommes donc c'est une révolution
d'une société moderne avec des
revendications modernes face à un régime
moyen-mageur et répressif la révolution
est déclenchée vous savez la révolution
ne réussit pas de jour au lendemain à
s'apprend peut-être des années même mais
en tout cas ce que les Iraniens et c'est
John generations c'est ce qui me veulent
pas le régime islamique d'Iran mais
alors qui pourrait prendre la tête de
l'Iran pour remplacer le régime actuel
en 1979 komeny était le leader de
l'opposition religieuse c'est lui qui a
finalement pris le pouvoir et qui a
instauré la République islamique
aujourd'hui la révolte n'est portée par
aucune figure ce qui peut être
problématique pour déclencher une
révolution